Healthcare.
Education.
Water.
Nutrition.
There are so many pockets of the world that still are in
extreme poverty.
A billion people living on $1.25 is wrong!
It's just wrong!
And we've got to do something about it.
All of the things that lead to poverty alleviation come from
economic growth.
And we believe the entrepreneurs in these economies are the
engines of growth.
We know that there are people out there that can make this
world a better place.
And we want to get behind them!
Thanks to a generous gift from Bob and Dottie King, Stanford
University is launching a bold new initiative.
I think what the gift allows us to do is it allows us to
think in much bigger terms about what it is that we could
do.
We are going to create an Institute housed in the greater
School of Business to bring our knowledge about
entrepreneurship to entrepreneurs who are trying to make a
better life.
It's called the Stanford Institute for Innovation in
Developing Economies.
The Institute has a long name.
But we nicknamed it SEED.
SEED signifies possibilities.
Something small that has the potential to grow.
It means "hope".
SEED is going to include three components: research,
education and dissemination, and what we're calling an "on
the ground" component.
Each part of the Institute reinforces and supports the
others.
We will conduct research on how to develop management skills
and create an entrepreneurial spirit.
In the education and dissemination part of the Institute, we
will develop courses for our students, courses for
entrepreneurs from developing economies, and we will take
the knowledge that we have created in the research arm of
the Institute and disseminate it very broadly using the web
and information technology.
We also recognize the need of collaboration with on-the-
ground people working with local groups to make things
happen.
Engineering students, medical students, business students
coming together to produce new goods and services that don't
exist now.
And then we're going to take existing entities from small
size to much greater size.
Stanford is a creature of Silicon Valley.
And Silicon Valley is a creature of Stanford.
And what SEED is going to be able to do, which no one else
has ever done, is to bring all of that genetic code, all of
that secret sauce, to the places around the world that can
benefit from it most.
It's not just going to be a think tank; it's going to be
results that are going to change people's lives.
This is one of the largest gifts in Stanford's history.
This is a very exciting opportunity.
It is, frankly, for all of us, the opportunity of a
lifetime.
When I think about SEED and I think about the opportunity to
really make a contribution, we want to say thank you!
I mean we can't do it ourselves.
But I think Stanford University can do it.
It's going to happen!